cinéma avec la sortie d'une production
hollywoodienne signée d'un maître du
film d'action Sabine
et un cerveau pareil ça se monnaie à la
fin de chaque mission moyennant un gros
chèque sa mémoire est effacée pour
l'empêcher de divulguer des infos top
secret ça vaut être de la
science-fiction se lavage de cerveau ça
fait tout de même froid dans le dos je
l'ignore ils ont passé ma mémoire
sommes-nous juste une juxtaposition de
souvenirs est-ce que l'être humain a une
âme son désir de façonner l'univers à sa
manière à travers la technologie ce sont
toutes ces questions que posent la
science-fiction mais cette fois-ci gros
soucis pas d'argent à la clé trois ans
de sa vie effacés à jamais le FBI à ses
trousses et pour se remémorer son passé
notre amnésique ne dispose que de 19
indices dans une enveloppe et il y a le
cerveau
tellement bien même pas être tombé
amoureux de la belle Rachel comme si
embrassait ou ma tourne ça pouvait
s'oublier
il y a eu scène où elle se rend compte
qu'il ne la reconnaît pas du tout c'est
horrible je crois que pour une femme
c'est la pire des choses qui puisse
arriver c'est la pire des humiliations
côté romantisme dur dur le futur mais
que les fans de John Wu se rassurent
cascade poursuit infernale explosion il
y a là tous les ingrédients du bon gros
film d'action comme cette course à moto
impressionnante
sur le tournage c'était beaucoup plus
calme sans trucage un film bourré-clin
d'oeil au maître du suspense Hitchcock
avec un Ben Affleck ou faux air de
caribandes
il y a deux moments du film kitchcock
m'inspiré celui où Ben Affleck et
poursuivi par un train une référence à
la mort aux trousses et puis la fameuse
poursuite à moto
ne restera peut-être pas dans les
mémoires très longtemps un thriller de
deux heures nerveux efficace haltan sur
le thème de la manipulation mentale un
peu inquiétant